ja
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
wünsche einen schönen guten morgen
begrüßte sie beim pressegespräch mit
gesundheitsminister anschober den
minister aber mit stadtrat hackern und
in garagen flieger und darf sich
gesundheitsminister werden
an einem besonderen zeichen geben
wahrscheinlich dass wir da sein können
dass wir etwas den ausgleich
auch für diese gäste offensiver in ganz
österreich machen können vielleicht
beginn kurz zu ende
ein paar sätze zur aktuellen situation
was konkret betrifft das ist der
hintergrund unter anders wir haben die
situation dass wir mitarbeiter
doch sehr deutlich sind die zahlen in
österreich haben auch heute wieder
verdrängt
wir sehen dass wir konstant sind das ist
genau das ziel gewesen
wir sind
wir müssen in paris
die möglichen anwendungen zu setzen und
zu weit und das heißt nur eine frage zu
reduzieren
aufstand zu achten bei der
berufsberatung oder einzuhalten
wir setzen ganz österreich in allen
bundesländern weil ich wissen will ich
auch in allen bereichen sehr stark wie
in der welt
das bedeutet wir haben die investoren
auf gras ist von konkreten zukommen
werden sieben regeln halten
für arbeit welcher weiter wie es in den
letzten wochen heißt es wird sich auf
die besten fragen
das heißt es hat sich sprunghaft das ist
gut das ist wichtig damit sie infiziert
personen identifizieren können und auch
aktionen aufgerufen
wir setzen auch sehr stark auf
zusätzliche des sogenannten
ganz wichtig
so sehr sehr intensiv in ganz österreich
geleistet wird unser den bereichen
führung die massen sind die wichtigsten
sind deswegen wichtig weil wir erstens
dadurch eine gesamt bestandsaufnahme der
tatsächlichen realen situation stichwort
ungeziefer haben und damit auch menschen
die noch nicht infiziert sind oder noch
keine symptome haben presse automatisch
sind oder generell keine symptome habe
haas und beschwingt identifizieren
können und außerdem infektions kreislauf
herausholen
das ist eine chance das ist ein
zusätzliches instrument und ich bedanke
mich sehr bald wieder mit macht und ganz
großartige zusammenarbeit in der
vorbereitung wie ich höre dass den
soldaten in den soldaten in stark
sehr vorbildlich bedanke ich nicht
generell für die ausgezeichnete
zusammenarbeit auf allen ebenen zwischen
den studenten die bisher den soldaten
dennoch veränderte die wir bei anderen
zeit
mysterium für den lieblingsseiten
die situation
ja etwas sehr sehr schwierigen situation
sind wir sind personell
ausgestattet waren und jetzt internet
kaufen werden
versuchen dementsprechend auch
nachzukommen was unsere herausforderung
in dieser situation ist ich kann ihnen
noch eine aktuelle zahl sagen wir haben
ja mittlerweile die online-anmeldung
seit einiger zeit nämlich seit 32
stunden gut 32 stunden in betrieb
und wir haben mittlerweile fast 100.000
anmeldungen bereits das heißt dazu
laufen das interesse der bevölkerung ist
sehr sehr groß
obwohl es gestern und sie wissen es eine
erste start unterbrechung gegeben hat
von rom zwei stunden und dennoch fast
100.000 anmeldungen
das ist das zeichen und das signal das
die bevölkerung gut mitmacht und dafür
bedanke ich mich wirklich herzlich danke
herr innenminister bitte
vielen dank meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren
unser gemeinsames ziel ist es die massen
testungen erfolgreich durchzuführen um
infektionsketten zu durchbrechen und
hier jetzt in der wiener stadthalle ist
ein sichtbares zeichen mit das
zusammenwirken aller kräfte notwendig
ist und das effizient und rasch
durchführen zu können
die strategische reserve der republik
das österreichische bundesheer leistet
dazu einen großen beitrag genauso aber
auch wie das rote kreuz und der
arbeiter-samariter-bund es gibt eine
enge kooperation zwischen den
gesundheitsbehörden und der polizei
die polizei sichert all diese
teststationen mit bereitschaft einheiten
einsatzeinheiten und streifen damit auch
da der ablauf gesichert ist und die
sichtbarkeit dargestellt wird wie
wichtig das zusammenwirken ist zwischen
der polizei auf der einen seite den
gesundheitsbehörden auf der anderen aber
vor allem gemeinsam in der partnerschaft
mit der bevölkerung
die polizei selbst stellt sich auch
diesen testungen wir werden über 100
test straßen demnächst in betrieb nehmen
um auch hier polizistinnen und
polizisten sicherheit zu geben weil auch
unser eigenes interesse ja darin besteht
gerade auch im polizeilichen bereich
infektionsketten zu durchbrechen
die polizei testet mit eigenen kräften
und in zusammenarbeit mit dem roten
kreuz und auch hier wieder ganz klar
sichtbar die verschränkung zwischen
zivilen einsatzorganisationen und die
blaulichtorganisationen im
zusammenwirken schaffen dann das was wir
jetzt gerade anstreben nämlich dass wir
den menschen in österreich sicherheit
geben können wenn sie diese testung in
anspruch nehmen und daher mein appell
es ist jetzt die chance wenn wir die
lockerungen stück für stück vornehmen
ist jetzt die chance durch die massen
testungen wieder ein stück weit mehr
sicherheit zu bekommen und wenn ich
infiziert bin aber keine symptome habe
gleichzeitig die gelegenheit ist auch
wieder andere zu schützen
daher mein appell nehmen wir gemeinsam
diese testmöglichkeiten war sie können
und sicherheit geben sie führen auch
dazu wieder dass wir die normalität die
wir uns alle so er bei sinnen
hoffentlich bald wieder eintritt und
weil das oft ein thema war selbst jetzt
auch im zuge der neuen maßnahmen die
gesetzt werden um infektionsketten zu
durchbrechen
die polizei wird auch weiterhin nicht
einfach so im privaten bereich
hausbesuche machen dass carola wir uns
aber schon schützen wir uns schauen wir
wechselseitig aufeinander und lassen wir
uns messen
jetzt legen dank herr stadtrat bitte
jetzt klammern und herren sehr geehrte
kolleginnen herr minister so ich war
herzlich willkommen in unserer stadt
halle
wir haben in den letzten tagen doch eine
organisatorische und logistische
meisterleistung hinbekommen und daher
möchte mich bedanken bei allen
organisationen die daran beteiligt sind
und jetzt seit tagen wirklich tag und
nacht durcharbeiten und das möglich zu
machen was wir unseren wienerinnen und
wienern unserer bevölkerungen ganz so
lang versprochen haben nämlich die
möglichkeit zu bekommen
den test zu machen auf kuwait 19 mal
bedanken bei den arbeiter samariter
wir bedanken weil meiner feuerwehr
möchte bedanken bei meiner rettung und
möchten besonders auch gedanken weil
österreichische bundesheer sozusagen
arbeit war exzellent oder ist exzellent
und direktoren glaube ich was gelungen
ist sind so einer kurzer zeit
organisatorisch aber auch personell
der ablauf von prozessen in zu bekommen
es sind ja heute in einer von drei
standorten die wir ihm machen
das ist ein experiment das es in dieser
form noch nicht gegeben hat in europa
gab es noch keine massen leistung der
bevölkerung in dieser vorgang in einer
millionenstadt
das war auch der grund warum wir
besondere konzentration gehabt haben wie
kann das überhaupt in irgendeiner form
stattfinden und bewältigbar sein und das
ist uns glaube ich gut gelungen
wir sind hier am kleinsten standort und
das wird besonders paradox klingen wenn
wir dann drinnen sind und sie sehen wie
riesengroß da aufbau hier herinnen ist
aber es ist der kleinste standort von
den dreien die haben doch einen zweiten
standort in der st marx halle im dritten
bezirk und der größte aller unserer
standort in der messehalle im zweiten
bezirk
ich glaube dass es eine wichtige
maßnahme ist wenn der bevölkerung
versprochen wird dass sie auch wenn sie
nicht symptomatisch ist wenn die
menschen keine symptome haben wenn die
menschen nicht besonderen zielgruppen
gehören trotzdem ein test angeboten wird
und vorgeschlagen wird das durch zu
führen halte ich es für absolut
notwendig dieses versprechen auch
einzelne ist und das war auch der grund
warum wir in dieser geschichte und
selbst so engagiert haben
ich habe mir das österreichische
bundesheer für den ersten teil des
testverfahrens die organisation so gut
hinbekommen hat für die gesamten bereich
der antigen test und wir stellen dann
sozusagen direkt dahinter als
gesundheitsbehörde weil wir uns dazu
entschieden haben wir wollen nicht die
menschen noch warten lasse und auch kein
hin und herschicken organisieren
zwischen dem positiven antigen test und
den kontroll leistungen
mit pcr test ob man daher schritt direkt
dahinter nach dem vorliegen des
ergebnisses vom anti gehendes die
gesundheitsbehörde und macht vor
inhaltlich gesamte aufgabe menschen
bekommen so vorteil und beschied
menschen bekommen sofort ein kollege ist
damit man kein zweites mal ab streichen
müssen
wenn er sofort mit den ersten schritten
des contact racing beginnen und somit so
rasch wie möglich in den normalmodus der
vorgangsweise der gesundheitsbehörde
einschreiten können warum nicht durch
die große anzahl von menschen von der
wir ausgehen dass zu diesen test kommen
werden unsere eigenen
gesundheitsbehörden lahmzulegen oder
auch durch die anmeldung unter t straße
der sie lanz und ich bin sehr froh dass
diese technischen probleme gestern ihre
gelöst werden konnten hat ein bisschen
verunsicherung verursacht aber es schaut
so aus ist das jetzt gut im griff
bekommen ist und dass da wir müssen uns
auch bedanken bei der die techniker die
da gestern selbst schließlich stunden
verbrachte um das wieder in den griff zu
bekommen
aber das ist auch ganz klar in der
vorlauf auf die art und weise passiert
dann muss es dazwischen ein bisschen
improvisation geben bisher zufrieden
dass wir den zeitplan einhalten können
und wünsche dann noch interessant der
fotografien und aufnahmen da drin und
sind beeindruckende bilder aber wie
gesagt 'denk muss immer dran
es ist der kleinste standort den
herzlichen dank es sind dank herr
general bitte ja schönen guten morgen
von meiner seite
meine herrn bundesminister herr stadtrat
ich bedanke mich sehr für die
anerkennenden worte tatsächlich ist es
für das österreichische bundesheer eine
große herausforderung diese
organisatorische und logistische
unterstützung zu leisten
das bundesheer war ja von anfang der
kogit krise an gefordert einerseits im
grenzmanagement wir haben zur
sicherstellung und gewährleistung der
sicherheitspolizeilichen assistenz wie
sie wissen in der ersten jahreshälfte
auch eine teilmobilmachung vollzogen und
nun geht es darum
die angeordneten massen testungen die
der österreichischen bevölkerung
angeboten werden an zahlreichen
teststationen zu unterstützen
das österreichische bundesheer wird
hierzu über 5000 soldaten zum einsatz
bringen um über 93 teststationen und
etwa 850 teams zu bilden haben in
jeweils der stärke von 5 personen
soldatinnen und soldaten die die
organisatorische abwicklung dieser
testungen gewährleisten sollen in enger
zusammenarbeiten und im zusammenwirken
mit den gesundheitsbehörden mit den
sicherheitsorganisationen und den
anderen verantwortlichen dienst stellen
ich möchte daher die gelegenheit nutzen
mich bei den verantwortlichen
kommandanten aber vor allem bei den
soldatinnen und soldaten zu bedanken für
diese leistung die hier erbracht wird es
ist auch ein großer anteil an
freiwilligkeit ich darf erwähnen dass
auch aus dem verteidigungsministerium
selbst bis hinauf zum zum brigadiers
dienstgrad sich soldaten gemeldet haben
um bei diesen feststellungen mitzuwirken
und ihren beitrag zu leisten weil
natürlich auch rein quantitativ das eine
sehr hohe anforderung ist wenn die
einsätze die darüber hinaus vom
österreichischen bundesheer zu leisten
sind mit etwa 900 soldaten im ausland
mit über 1000 soldatinnen und soldaten
zur überwachung unserer südgrenze im
zusammenhang mit der verhinderung
illegaler migration dann sind diese
zusätzlichen kräfte team nun für die
massen leistungen zu stellen sind eine
große herausforderung für das
österreichische bundesheer wir sind aber
auch dankbar für die gelegenheit unsere
zusammenarbeit fähigkeit unserer
kooperationsfähigkeit hier unter beweis
stellen zu dürfen und ich darf berichten
dass bisher in der vorbereitung diese
zusammenarbeit ausgezeichnet
funktioniert dass wir hier in unserer
unterstützungs rolle
einen entsprechenden beitrag leisten
können
auf die soldatinnen und soldaten auch
sehr stolz sind und ich sehe diesen
massentest jüngern und den von der
bundesregierung eingeleiteten maßnahmen
hier mit sehr viel zuversicht entgegen
und ich glaube dass wir alle zusammen
einen beitrag leisten können
zur eindämmung der cobit krise damit uns
möglicherweise ein dritter lockdown
erspart bleibt vielen herzlichen dank
deswegen danke ich darf sie nun zum
zweiten teil ein laden nämlich zur
eigentlichen präsentation der test
straßen und dort werden ihnen die herren
auch für interviews zur verfügung
stellen